Would you pray with me?
Father, I ask that you'd help me now to be faithful to your word.
And I ask that you would come and cause us to experience a personal, close enjoyment of Jesus Christ in all his supremacies as our greatest hope.
I ask for this now in Jesus' name.
Amen.
I used to think when I read 1 Peter 315 that says, always be ready to make a defense to anyone who asks a reason for the hope that is in you, that it meant
Piper, you need to nail down three or four solid historical arguments for the resurrection.
And you need to nail down three or four solid historical arguments for the authority and truth of the Bible.
And I thank God that there are people who are called to do that because those arguments really do exist.
I don't think that's mainly what this verse means.
Because this church, those five churches throughout Asia Minor, they're just ordinary folk.
You know from chapter three, they're slaves.
They didn't know anything.
They didn't have any education.
The last thing they had was access to our sophisticated intellectual university-trained historians.
What then did it mean?
I think when he said this, that last phrase mattered, be prepared to make a defense to anyone who asks you for a reason for the hope that is in you.
It's in you.
So as I look on you, I believe that
The vast majority of you in this room right now, and probably those watching, have that hope that you are counting on eternal life.
You're counting on going to heaven instead of hell.
You're counting your sins being forgiven.
You're counting on all your guilt to be removed for one reason, Jesus.
I think for the vast majority in this room, somebody put a gun to your head right now and say, renounce Jesus or you're dead, you would not renounce Jesus.
I believe that.
That's the kind of people I think I'm preaching to.
And I think Peter would just say to you, so give a reason because you've got them.
You've got them.
They're in you.
Here's what.
That's chapter one, that's chapter three, verse 15 of 1 Peter, here's chapter one, verse three.
According to the great mercy, he has caused us to be born again.
According to God's great mercy, he caused us to be born again to a living hope through the resurrection of Jesus Christ from the dead, to an inheritance that is imperishable, undefiled, unfading, kept in heaven for you who by God's power are being guarded through faith.
for a salvation ready to be revealed in the last time.
So if somebody asks you this afternoon, what are you hoping in?
You can say, I'm hoping in eternal life.
Death is a doorway to Jesus.
I believe all my sins are forgiven.
I don't have any guilt anymore because of Jesus and I'm going to spend eternity happy with Jesus and they'll say,
Why do you believe that?
What will you say?
Well, there's two answers right there.
You say, because I've been born again.
Second, you say, reason number two, Jesus was raised from the dead.
Now, if you're like me, you think that's not enough.
gotta give a reason for the reason.
And then you gotta give a reason for the reason for the reason.
Odd infinitum, until you get to an absolutely incontrovertible argument, and guess what?
There is no such thing.
Meaning Satan
and all unbelievers can always say, why?
Like a four-year-old.
You cannot give a four-year-old enough answers for why anything exists.
Somebody will always say, at reason two, reason three, reason four, reason five, why do you believe that?
And I get paralyzed.
I don't have number three ready.
or four or five, so you don't give one.
That's not good.
I think Peter meant when somebody asks you for a reason for the hope that is in you, you should say, because I have been born again by the living God.
End of conversation.
That's not a conversation stopper for most people.
Like they will ask, so why do you think that?
Or what in the world is it?
And you might say, that's all for now.
We can talk later, but that's why.
That's my reason.
And they walk away thinking, what is that?
And at midnight, that night, because the law is written on their heart and they are created in the image of God and they know God and they're suppressing all kinds of knowledge of God, their heart's gonna say,
I wonder if you need to be born again to enter the kingdom of God.
You've done your job.
There are other reasons you can give, lots of them from your own experience.
Just don't be paralyzed by the fact that your reason for the reason for the reason is not yet in your head.
That may be a philosopher's job or a historian's job.
Your job is to say why you believe and you've got a reason
Yes, you do.
You may not think anybody else thinks it's enough.
It's enough for you.
You're gonna die for it, right?
You got a reason.
You're not dying for nothing.
I think one of the reasons we can give is this.
The supremacy of Jesus Christ.
That's a disadvantage.
season is, the supremacy of Jesus Christ.
So it seemed good to me in thinking through this message that we should spend time at the beginning of the series here lingering maybe a little longer over the supremacy of Jesus.
Namely the reality that there is no being in the universe
or outside the universe that is greater or superior to Jesus Christ, including God.
Because Jesus is God.
I have a burden.
I suppose this is the reason I was led to this.
I have a burden for you, for the church today, that the cultural and political
Spectacles are being thrust at you all day long.
It's on your phone.
It's on your flat screens at home.
They're being thrust at you.
These cultural phenomena, these political international affairs are the main thing.
These are supremely important.
People are talking about these.
So talk about these.
Type into your favorite AI assistant.
I should say chat GPD.
What are the great realities being discussed in our world today?
That's what I did.
Answer.
The geopolitical order is fracturing.
Climate change is irreversible.
Infertility causing demographic collapse in the Western countries.
Space as the new arena of great power competition.
The credibility of legacy institutions has collapsed or more immediately.
National Guard shooting in Washington or Hong Kong Fire or Russia, Ukraine or last night's Stockton shooting which will be all over the news when you get home.
those realities and many like them and they're cycling through all the time are presented as the great issues, right?
Those are the great issues of our day, just ask Chad GPT.
And my concern is that you, the sons and daughters of the living God,
Born again, never to die, living in the presence of God forever would believe it.
They're not.
They're not, I'm here to say.
It's what everybody's talking about.
How can it not be supremely important?
But we're like a submarine whose sonar has just gone out.
And all the alarms go off.
This is important because a turtle is swimming by.
And we can't detect an aircraft carrier five miles away.
So here at the beginning of the message in the series,
I'd like to try to reorient our sonar on the supremacy of Christ.
Colossians 1-18 says, in everything Christ is preeminent, in everything.
So consider the supremacy of his deity, equal with God, all of his attributes, radiance of his glory, exact imprint of his nature,
infinite boundless in all of His excellencies, the supremacy of His eternality, mind-boggling for a child, and for me, He never had a beginning.
Christ never had a beginning.
Alpha, Omega, consider the supremacy of His constancy never changing.
His character, his virtues, his commitments, the same yesterday, today, and forever.
Consider the supremacy of his knowledge, makes the Library of Congress look like a matchbox, makes all that information massive AI data centers look like a farmer's almanac, which by the way is ceasing to print this year after 200 years.
makes quantum physics in anything that ever entered Steve Hawking's head, looked like a first grade reader.
The supremacy of his wisdom, he's never been perplexed.
Nobody can counsel him.
He's never been confused about anything.
The supremacy of his authority on heaven and earth
No man can do anything without his permission.
He raises up kings, he puts down kings.
The supremacy of his providence, not a bird falls from the sky without his dictation.
No hair turns white or black without his decree, Jesus Christ.
The supremacy of his word, he upholds the universe with it.
He holds all beings, molecules, atoms, subatomic particles that nobody's ever yet discovered.
He holds them all together.
The supremacy of his power.
He walks on water.
He cleanses lepers.
He heals the lame.
He opens the eyes of the blind and makes the deaf hear.
Makes storms to rise and raises the dead with one word.
The supremacy of his purity.
He's never saying not one millisecond of a lustful thought or pride or undue anger, pure.
The supremacy of his trustworthiness, he has never, never will break his word, keeps all of his promises.
The supremacy of his justice, he will render all moral accounts settled either on the cross or in hell.
The supremacy of his patience.
I wouldn't exist without his patience.
Just postponing judgment further and further out so that more people can repent.
The supremacy of his sovereignty and his servant like obedience, he chose
to embrace the cross.
The supremacy of his meekness, lowliness, tenderness, he won't break a bruise, read or quench a smoldering flax.
The supremacy of his courage, he intentionally walked into the mouth of the lion and died for us.
The supremacy of his wrath, I think of all the
Big shots in the world today that huff and puff and brag and boast.
They're gonna cry out for the rocks to fall upon them so they don't have to face the wrath of the lamb.
That's coming.
The supremacy of His grace to cause us to be born again to a living hope.
The supremacy of His love willingly dies for us.
And the supremacy, finally though it's not finally, we're just scratching the surface
of his gladness.
Jesus Christ has been happy in the fellowship of the Trinity forever and ever and ever and always will be.
In fact, I think the happiness of the Trinity is the energy that created the universe so that he could share it.
Compared to Jesus and his manifold supremacies, world affairs are
as nothing.
That's based on a text.
Behold, the nations are like a drop from a bucket and are accounted as the dust on the scales.
All the nations are as nothing before Him.
They are accounted by Him as less than nothing and emptiness.
To whom then will you liken God or what likeness compare with Him?
So let's make a turn.
It's not a very big turn from the supremacy of Christ to supremacy of Christ, our hope, because that's what my assignment from Kenny is to talk about the supremacy of Christ as our hope.
There are three ways that
Hope is used in the New Testament.
And three ways that you use it almost every day.
And they're the same.
One, hope is a strong emotion of confident expectation.
It's a feeling.
It's something the heart does.
Like,
Romans 15-13, by the power of the Holy Spirit you abound in hope.
Second, it is the thing you hope for.
And third, it is the ground or basis of your hope.
All three of those are called hope.
For example, do you say to the coach of the Timberwolves, what are you hoping for in this game?
how your player is feeling about this game.
And he says, they're full of hope.
They're full of hope.
We're going to win this game.
That's the feeling inside.
And then you say to him, what are you hoping for?
And he says, victory.
Victory is our hope.
That's the second use of the word hope.
And third, he says, okay, three seconds left, it's your ball, bring it on the side.
What's your hope?
The ant man.
We're gonna give it to Anthony Edwards.
He is our hope.
What does that mean?
It means it's the basis of your hope.
You all use the word that way three different ways.
The feeling, the goal, the ground.
Everybody uses the word hope that way.
So does the New Testament.
I've already mentioned Romans 15, 13.
By the power of the Holy Spirit, you abound in hope.
That's the feeling, that's the energy inside.
And then there's the ground, Colossians 1, 27.
Christ in you, the hope of glory.
Because He's in you, you're gonna make it to glory.
And the one I wanna spend the rest of our time on,
is the goal.
What are you, at the beginning of this Advent season, at this point in your life, whether you're old like me or young like the kids, what are you hoping for?
What's the goal?
What is your greatest hope?
And I wanna persuade you that it ought to be, and I think for most of you, if you think it through is,
A personal and warm, close enjoyment of Christ in all His Supremacies.
A close, personal enjoyment of Christ in all His Supremacies should be your greatest hope.
greater than seeing loved ones again when you die, greater than never being sick, never being diseased or depressed or wounded or sad or lonely ever again, greater than never sinning again, greater than being glorified with Jesus, and greater than
being a part of the new heavens and the new earth.
So I want to persuade you of that fact.
Your greatest hope right now should be, and forever, a close, personal enjoyment of Jesus Christ in all his Supremacies.
If it's not, listen carefully and pray that he would become that for you.
I'll give you three reasons.
They're very short for why that should be your greatest hope.
Number one, because that's what Jesus wants for you.
Number two, that's what Paul experienced.
And number three,
That's what the new heavens and the new earth are for.
Let's take those one at a time.
This is what Jesus wants for you.
Here's how he prayed for you.
And we know it's for you because he says in verse 20, I'm not only praying for these, but for those who would believe on me through their word.
That's personally prayed for every Christian in this room.
And here's what he's praying for you.
Verse 24, Father, I desire that they also whom you have given me may be with me where I am to see my glory.
He wants that.
He's asking the Father, grant that you, you Christian, would be with him
to see His glory.
That's gotta be your hope, because that's what He wants for you.
Paul in Titus 2, 13 calls that the blessed hope.
Hope.
We are waiting for our blessed hope, the appearing of the glory of our great God and Savior, Jesus Christ.
That's what Jesus
was praying for you to experience as your greatest hope, a close, personal enjoyment of Christ in all his supremacies.
Jesus wants that for you.
Amazing.
Number two, Paul experienced this.
You remember Philippians?
He's in jail.
And he's writing to his beloved Philippian church that supported him so lovingly.
And he says, I am hard pressed.
This is verse 23 of chapter one.
I am hard pressed between the two, namely going to heaven or staying in ministry.
My desire is to depart and be one of the next two words.
Oh, you should know this.
Not to scold you.
With Christ.
To depart and be with Christ.
For that is far better than anything here.
Is it to you?
That's the issue this morning.
Is a close, personal enjoyment of Christ your greatest hope?
So you could say that with Paul.
better to depart and be with him.
He adds this in second Corinthians five eight.
Yes, we are of good courage and we would rather be away from the body and at home with the Lord, with the Lord at home with the Lord.
I lived 10 minute walk from here.
I was walking over today.
And somebody picked me up, bless your heart, because they had not plowed the sidewalk on the bridge.
And I was given thanks for this car that stopped.
And also wondering about the people who tripped all the way to the North Pole.
Like, I was so tired.
I lived 10 minutes from here and I lived there for 42 years.
4-2.
We raised five kids in that house.
We went through the deepest marital waters in that house.
We, goodness knows, spread dozens of Thanksgiving feasts with 12, 16, 18 people around the table.
It's whole.
I love this house.
God helped me not love it too much.
I love coming home to the neighborhood and to the house.
However, the reason God gave us this house with its tattered carpet and chipping paint and rotting eaves is to remind us it's not your home.
Home is great.
And you got a better one.
And it isn't a retirement complex in Phoenix.
Jesus!
Any day!
Paul experienced that.
And I want to maintain it.
I'm old.
I think I'm old.
I used to say,
60 was old, and then I turned 60, and I said, that's not old.
And I used to think 70 was old, and then I turned 70, and I said, that's not old.
And I used to think 80 was old.
It is.
I think.
I have about six weeks to go.
So here's the point.
Nonsense.
Every night I lie down, I think, my heart could stop before I wake up.
Of course, that's true for you too, but it's even more true for me.
Is it okay between you and Jesus?
How is it with you and Jesus?
Because if you die in your sleep at 3 a.m., you see Him.
He better not be a stranger.
So I say to him, I love you, I trust you, and you know what he says back to me?
He says it back every night.
He says, you John Piper are not destined for wrath, but to obtain salvation through your Lord.
me, Jesus Christ, who died for you so that whether you wake or sleep, you will live with me.
That's 1 Thessalonians 5, 9, and 10 in case you want to use it.
There's no copyright.
What a way to lay your head down on the pillow.
No condemnation.
I died for you.
You died a night coming home.
So second argument for why you should make a close, personal enjoyment of Jesus in all his supremacies adds your greatest hope is that Paul experienced it and called us into it.
Last argument for why you should do that.
Namely that the heavens and the earth, the new heavens and the new earth
are designed for that.
So now it's true, it's true that the cosmos, all the galaxies and the numbers, they have to create words for these numbers.
That all the galaxies, the solar system and the earth
all the mountains and rivers and oceans and everything broken on earth and everything broken in us, the whole creation and the new humanity is gonna be set right.
It's gonna be new in every way that is good.
It's gonna be new.
That is our Christian hope, it is.
But I wanna make something crystal clear.
And the kids listen up because
You should ask your mom and dad about this at lunch today.
Jesus Christ today carries the universe in his pocket like a peanut.
You got that?
Remember, say, what did you say about peanut?
He said Jesus Christ carries the universe in his pocket like a peanut.
Compared to the glories of the Creator of the universe, the cosmos is as nothing.
Compared.
It's pretty amazing, I admit.
I love astronomy and biology and just opening my eyes across the bridge.
I love this world.
I do.
I'm glad it's going to be made new.
It's nothing compared to Jesus.
Here's the text for that.
Do you remember in the great eight, there's no greater chapter in the Bible than Romans eight?
Do you remember verse 17 where it says, if you suffer with him, you'll be glorified with him.
All right?
If you Christian are willing
to deny yourself, take up your cross, follow Him, suffer with Him, whatever is required of you to be faithful to Him, you're gonna be glorified with Him.
Here's the next thing he says.
The creation waits with eager longing for the revealing of the sons of God.
It's not the other way around, folks.
We're not waiting for the new creation.
It's waiting for us.
The main thing in Romans 8 is not, oh, wow, there's going to be a new heavens and a new earth.
That's where we're going the other way around.
The whole creation is saying, oh, wow, the children of God are going to be made glorious and we can be part of that.
That's amazing.
This universe is about you glorified like Jesus.
That's just incredible.
No, it's not incredible.
It's true.
I'll say it again.
I mean, Paul says it again.
Verse 21, the creation itself will be set free from its bondage to corruption and obtain what?
The freedom of the glory of the children of God takes your breath away.
We don't inherit the glory of the new creation.
It inherits ours.
It's a peanut.
And you shine like the sun in the
glory of your Father if you have a close, personal enjoyment of Jesus in all his supremacy.
So what's the main point of that Romans 8 section?
What's the main point?
The main point is that the new heavens and the new earth
are designed to celebrate the glory of the children of God.
That's why the universe exists.
The universe exists to celebrate the glory of the children of God.
What is that glory?
It is the glory of Christ because you have been brought into it and glorified with his
glory.
And why do you share that glory?
There's a good reason to give in 1 Peter 3.15.
Why do you share that glory?
Because you have a close, personal relationship of enjoyment with Jesus in all his Supremacy.
So I conclude at the beginning of Advent,
at the Lord's table that you're gonna have in just a moment.
I conclude that a close, personal enjoyment of Jesus Christ in all his supremacists is our greatest hope because one, that's what Jesus wants for you.
Two, that's what Paul experienced and invites you into and three,
That's why the new heavens and the new earth are coming.
Let's pray.
Father, I know I feel probably a greater burden for this because I'm old.
I do pray it for the younger people so that they don't waste their lives thinking that the news
or music or sports or movies are the main thing.
They're a peanut.
I pray that we would exalt Christ.
We're gonna sing and may we all feel you Christ are the feast in the house of Zion.
Has this in your name, Jesus?